[BACKGROUND VOICES]
NANCY LUBLIN >> Hello, YouTube. My name is
Nancy Lublin. I'm the CEO of DoSomething dot
org.
So, I have a suggestion for President Obama,
or any world leader who wants to engage in
the Middle East peace process. I think that
we should ban clothing in the Middle East.
Imagine this: Everyone in the Middle East,
all the Palestinians, all Jews, everyone,
was naked. There would be no more suicide
bombers because you wouldn't be able to hide
any of those things in your clothing. And
there would be a much greater sense of humility
because people would walk around going, "Ooo,
that looks like me. Ooo-ooo, that's kind of
small."
So, um, that's my solution for Middle East
peace.